what happened when you uh auditioned for
Avatar like that's a big movie you
wanted the role I take it no not really
no I wouldn't you're crazy it's so great
what do you mean I'm crazy no it's great
no I think it's funny that you audition
for something you really don't even want
you didn't even well here's what here's
what it is here's what happened so I get
this I got this agent at the time uh
John Burnham he's an old style guy and
he's like you know he's excited they get
excited look Jim wants to meet with you
and I'm like all right why not and but
in the back of my head I'm like am I
gonna do this I mean you know what what
is this thing he's shooting four movies
at once I didn't I didn't even there's
no script but it's like a general I mean
go down there meet him so I drive all
the way to Long Beach and where I live
in Glendale Long Beach is like you gotta
pack a tent you gotta plan for the night
so I go
so I drive to Long Beach and he he's
like he's got like a an airport Hangar
he's like he's got a building that's the
size of Long Beach and I go in there and
I meet him and you know it's it's kind
of impressive it's it he's showing me
around it's like Cirque du Soleil down
there he's got actors there they're
they're they're on trapezius they're
jumping around they're flying through
the air the only you know they're report
they're working out stunts and [__] and
he meets me and I don't know what's
going to happen and we're talking and he
says this is the deal you know this is
the the part is this and and if you if
you get it you're probably gonna have to
to move to New Zealand for like in nine
years because it's going to take us like
nine years
you don't want to live in New Zealand
yeah dude I barely want to go out on the
road because I worry about my stupid
cats so right so there's no script but
he says here read this is the part you
know sit down with it read it and then
we're going to do an audition and I'm
like what so I I get the script and I
sit there for like 45 minutes and I read
it and before this he takes he's got
like a museum of himself down there you
can go look at the the Titanic and that
was kind of interesting I'm not open to
the public and then like he says are you
ready or you know and then he brings me
into a room with a bunch of other people
the acrobats and other people that were
working there I have no sense of what
things look like there's you know blue
screens around but I'm just floating
with this with these lines uh the guys
like a scientist or and he's got a
drinking problem not sure what the guy
from uh Flight of the Concords got the
part so I'm just scrambling to do this
thing and then I left and I was like
thank God I don't think that's gonna
happen I don't have to move to New
Zealand I don't I didn't even want to be
presented with the choice Howard I
didn't even I that's the worst thing is
that you don't want to do something but
then your agent says they want you to do
it and then you're like oh [__] so now I
got to sit here and think about how am I
going to live in New Zealand for two
years what's that going to do to me you
know